algunos de ustedes saben que disfruto
mucho comer un delicioso aguacate a
pesar de que tiene apariencia de vegetal
en realidad es una fruta
digamos que consumo dos aguacates por
día y vamos a decir que consumo dos
aguacates por día durante seis días hay
varias maneras de pensar en cuántos
aguacates consumí puedo decir hoy en
consumo dos aguacates al día y voy a
hacer eso durante seis días así que voy
a sumar seis dos juntos
22 22 22 tengo 62 aquí y puedo sumar los
entonces dos más dos es cuatro más 12 6
más dos es 8 más 12 10 más 2 llegamos a
12 y todo esto está muy bien pero hay
una manera más fácil de expresar esta
suma que se repite
una forma es tratar esto como una
multiplicación
y en vez de escribir 6 veces el 2 y
sumarlo todo los matemáticos han
encontrado una manera más adecuada de
abordar esto se trata de decir bien
vamos a sumar un número considerable de
dos cuantos dos voy a sumar tenemos seis
de esos dos y vamos a proponer un
símbolo a utilizar para esto vamos a
usar esta cosa que parece una equis así
que seis veces dos o seis por dos puede
verse como la suma repetida a la que
damos el mismo tratamiento
así que 6 veces 2 será igual a 12
ahora vamos a verlo de otra manera si
alguien te pregunta cuánto es cuatro
veces tres o cuatro por tres pausa el
vídeo y trata de hacerlo como una suma
repetida igual que lo hicimos aquí
arriba bien una forma de interpretar
esto es aquí tenemos cuatro tres así que
podemos decir que esto es igual a tres
más
3 3 y 3 13 6 393 es 12 es probable que
estés familiarizado con contar de tres
en tres y dices 3 6 9 12
por curiosidad cuánto crees que sea tres
veces cuatro pausa el vídeo e intenta
hacerlo como una suma repetida y observa
que se te ocurrió podemos interpretar
esto como tres cuatros y podemos decir
que será 444
si contamos de cuatro en cuatro
tenemos 4 8 12
así que esto resulta en 12 algo
interesante es que al menos para estos
dos ejemplos llegué al mismo resultado
cuatro veces 3 tiene el mismo resultado
que 3 veces 4 qué interesante me
pregunto si esto es cierto todo el
tiempo en fin el mensaje importante en
este vídeo es que puedes pensar en la
multiplicación como una suma que se
repite